and that's why charles dickens is one of  the greatest writers  in history  numbers versus letters  i know what you're thinking numbers have  the obvious  advantage right they're old roman  numerals you can  write them however before you start  getting on your number rant people and  i don't want to see you in the comments  until you listen to this part here's  what letters have  okay i'll be the first to admit there's  only 26 of them trust me i don't feel  good about that either  it's so fine here's the thing i've never  seen a number do something a letter  has sorry excuse me if you  thought about this for longer than two  seconds you can spell  numbers but you can't number  letters thank you for watching  [Music]  you